jemanden in die wüste schicken
eine beziehung beenden
es ist aus mit
es ist aus mit uns
sie hat mich in die wüste geschickt
ein schürzenjäger
ein
ein schützen
sein
ein mann der ständig frauen umwirbt
dieser typ ist ein richtiger
schürzenjäger
das eis brechen
die stimmung verbessern
die stimmung war
an
was mache ich bloß hier
die stimmung ist miserabel
wie könnte ich nur das eis brechen
hast du einen
neue frisur
ihre frisur
wie aufmerksam von dir
ich war heute beim friseur
er ist richtig sympathisch
jetzt hat er end
ich das eis gebrochen
jetzt hat er endlich das eis gebrochen
im eimer sein
kaputt seien erschöpft sein
99 100
98 99 100
das training war
sehr anstrengend
das training war heute sehr anstrengend
wie ich sehe bist du richtig gut in form
ja aber jetzt bin ich voll im eimer
blau sein
betrunken sein
schaut euch diesen typen an
er ist total betrunken
unglaublich er ist total blau
blaumachen
nicht zur arbeit gehen seinen
verpflichtungen
nicht nachkommen
nicht zur arbeit gehen seinen
verpflichtungen nicht nachkommen
seht nur er liegt da wie eine tote
fliege
kein wunder er war ja gestern auch total
betrunken
wenn das bloß der chef sehen könnte
ich habe solche kopfschmerzen
ich habe
solche kopfschmerzen
ich glaube ich muss nach hause gehen
ich glaube
ich muss nach hause gehen
ich habe es gewusst jetzt macht er
blau
wieder blau
das haar in der suppe suchen
nur das negative sehen eine
pessimistische einstellung haben
schau wie schön die kinder zusammen
spielen nur wie schön die kinder
zusammen spielen
und dieser wunderschönen sonnenuntergang
wirklich toll wirklich toll wenn nur
dieser blöde vogel nicht wäre
wenn
du gehst mir auf die nerven
bist du zufrieden
wie bist du zufrieden
immer suchst du das haar in der suppe
das hast du jetzt davon die miesepeter
jemandem in die suppe spucken
jemandes pläne durchkreuzen jemandem
etwas verderben
das ist das letzte
saison
das ist das letzte rennen der saison
heute hole ich mir die goldmedaille
diese kinder durchkreuzen meine pläne
diese kinder
durchkreuzen meine pläne
ich kann es kaum glauben
ihr habt mir meine pläne verdorben
diese kinder haben mir in die suppe
gespuckt
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal